tout un symbole la grille d'honneur du
domaine de dampierre à dampierre en
yvelines va se refaire une beauté
mercredi 13 janvier a eu lieu la dépose
d'un des deux vantaux par les ateliers
saint jacques de la fondation de
coubertin restauration consiste d'abord
à une recherche stratigraphique des
couches de peinture pour identifier les
finitions ensuite on démonte l'ensemble
des pièces qui composent cet ouvrage et
on les restaure la grille a été installé
par les duc de luynes au xviiie siècle
elle n'a jamais eu de restauration
aujourd'hui évidemment elle souffre de
l'usure de la rouille qui l'a attaqué
les couleurs qui ne sont plus des des
commandes et assemblage qui ont cassé la
grille d'honneur sera de nouveau au
domaine dans deux ans en attendant dans
le château les chartes entier sont à
pied d'oeuvre pour faire les relevés en
vue de la restauration de la charpente
le château de dampierre a été construit
à la fin du xviie siècle et depuis cette
période il n'a subi qu'une seule
campagne de restauration qui est il ya
presque deux cents ans est évidemment
presque 200 ans après il était
nécessaire d'intervenir on voit les bois
déjà fin déjà la couverture les ardoises
était à bout de souffle
on voit les coûts les charpentes qui
sont abîmés les chevrons qui sont cassés
des éléments qui sont exposés au zoo
même s'ils sont à l'abri des plombs qui
sont pourris le chantier global atteint
près de 50 millions d'euros et sera
terminée courant 2022 sur le logis